bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
la pandemia de kobe 19 tuvo y sigue
teniendo graves impactos no solo en el
sector de la salud sino también en otros
aspectos de nuestras sociedades uno de
los más afectados fue el de la educación
en todo el mundo millones de niños se
vieron impactados en mayor o en menor
medida por el cierre de las escuelas
durante los confinamientos sin embargo
francia fue uno de los países que logró
reabrir rápidamente las escuelas y hoy
nos acompaña uno de los arquitectos de
esta política y él es el ex ministro de
educación del gobierno de manuel macro
no hablamos del señor yo michelle
blanquea el señor blanquea es máster en
filosofía doctor en derecho público y
también doctor honoris causa en ciencias
sociales de la universidad simón bolívar
viene para compartir con nosotros su
experiencia en lo que fue el manejo de
la epidemia en el sistema educativo
francés así como los aprendizajes y
también las reflexiones que quedan
después de esta crisis señor brawn queda
bienvenido a otras 24 muchas gracias
quiero comenzar hablándole de una fecha
clave 12 de marzo del año 2020 el
presidente macrón decide cerrar el país
cómo reaccionan ustedes y ante esta
emergencia
y tan de enormes proporciones como logra
establecer a la escuela como una
prioridad política para lograr que
justamente se reabra
bueno cuando se tomó esta decisión de
parte del presidente de la república fue
una decisión muy inmediata él había
creado
unos días antes el el nuevo consejo
científico y él había este consejo
científico había dicho que había que
cerrar rápidamente entonces fue una
sorpresa para todo el mundo
estábamos de cierta manera preparados
pero de otra manera no lo estábamos
habíamos empezado a trabajar a la escala
de unas regiones que ya habíamos cerrado
para tomar en cuenta la situación
sanitaria
pero de un día para el otro tuvimos que
cerrar todo el país y entonces tener dos
prioridades que eran en primer lugar
hacer enseñanza asistencia y en segundo
lugar
para capaces de tener cada día 30.000
niños que hagan los niños de los de las
personas que trabajaban en las
instituciones de salud
estos estas dos prioridades
y la asumimos y pero nos permite yo de
ver que en primer lugar la enseñanza a
distancia es sumamente importante en tal
si tales circunstancias pero no puede
reemplazar todas las virtudes de la
escuela física y entonces tuve
rápidamente la convicción que habría que
reabrir muy rápidamente y en segundo
lugar el hecho de hacer la
escolarización de 30.000 niños de los
personales de la de los hospitales vemos
me muestro que no había tanto peligro a
hacerlo si había un protocolo sanitario
riguroso y por eso hemos elaborado un
protocolo bastante riguroso pero que nos
permitió de reabrir el 11 de mayo de
2020 y a partir de este momento
vimos con el presidente de la rúbrica
bono la convicción fuerte que fue que la
escuela era la primera prioridad de la
sociedad y había que construir todo esto
fue todo toda nuestra estrategia general
alrededor de una escuela abierta para
tener los niños como prioridad de
nuestra sociedad usted habla hoy por hoy
de una escuela abierta no sólo en el
sentido literal de mantener la
institución asequible para los niños
sino también en un sentido digamos
filosófico más amplio como una
herramienta para la construcción de lo
que se llama una sociedad abierta que se
refiere y puede ampliar nos un poquito
está esta reflexión y para mí la crisis
tiene muchas consecuencias negativas
sobre la educación a la escala del mundo
por ejemplo las cifras de la unesco nos
muestra que 11 millones de niñas
supuestamente no regresarán a la escuela
después de esta crisis eso es sumamente
grave después de muchos progresos en el
siglo 20 esta crisis nos hace hacer
pasos atrás entonces
debemos reaccionar frente a eso y ver
cuáles son los actos positivos que
podemos tener
en este contexto entonces lo que lo que
pienso es que en primer lugar la escuela
abierta es un concepto básico que quiere
decir que debe haber escuela para todos
los niños del mundo todos los niños del
mundo deben ir a la escuela
eso es el derecho fundamental del niño
es básico pero en segundo lugar yo pongo
en relación el concepto de escuela
abierta con el concepto de sociedad
abierta eso quiere decir que debemos
concebir una escuela donde preparamos el
niño para el futuro lo que quiere decir
dar los saberes fundamentales
leer escribir contar espectar el otro
pero también adaptarse a distintas sus
instintos aspectos del mundo futuro en
particular tener una educación
tecnológica que permite de no ser
esclavo de las tecnologías sino de ser
maestros de las tecnologías y
discúlpeme usted habla por ejemplo de
que no hay que comparar o si hay que
comparar internacionalmente con humildad
los sistemas educativos pero digamos que
una de las cosas que trajo la pandemia
es que desnudó muchas de las
desigualdades que existen en un
continente como el nuestro en américa
latina' muchos de los niños se tuvieron
que quedar encerrados colombia tuvo un
confinamiento extremadamente largo por
ejemplo y los y cuando pasamos a la
virtualidad muchos de los niños ni
siquiera tenían esas herramientas
entonces quiero preguntarle por esa
irrupción de la tecnología en el sistema
educativo cuál es que es lo positivo y
qué es lo negativo
pero sencillamente lo positivo es que
necesitamos la enseñanza a distancia
como lo ha mostrado la crisis y en
segundo lugar aún cuando no cuando la
escuela está abierta puede ser muy útil
de utilizar los computadores para
ciertas interacciones pero al mismo
tiempo
hay que decir que
hemos visto que la enseñanza a distancia
no es el equivalente de la de la
enseñanza en presencia y que
especialmente para los dos niños de la
escuela primaria y de la escuela
secundaria
y hay una necesidad de ir a la escuela
porque hay una dimensión de
conocimiento por supuesto pero también
una dimensión psicológica y una
dimensión de sociabilidad también una
dimensión de salud porque hay muchos
niños que comen bien en la escuela y no
en la familia y entonces cuando se
cierran las escuelas por todas estas
razones se aumentan las desigualdades
eso nos muestra al contrario que la
escuela más que nunca en nuestra
sociedad en sociedades es un instrumento
de igualdad y señora blanca qué
repercusiones cree que vamos a enfrentar
porque por ejemplo el banco mundial
aplaudió las medidas que usted tomó en
francia como que se tomó su gobierno
pero por ejemplo en américa latina habla
de un retroceso de una década qué
repercusiones vamos a tener como
consecuencia de no haber mantenido esas
escuelas abiertas y hablando sobre todo
el tema de la salud mental que es una
algo que ha salido a colación pues
muchísimo en estos tiempos no sí
y todo el mundo va a pagar el precio de
tener escuelas cerradas entonces ahora
la gran cuestión es el gran desafío es
de invertir para que haya una especie de
ahora de
nueva etapa donde
haremos esfuerzos financieros para tener
escuelas en todo el mundo para pagar
bien a los maestros para hacer una buena
formación para ellos no es un asunto
marginal es el asunto de preparación de
nuestras sociedades en el futuro
entonces la
el tema es a nivel mundial por eso es un
tema que se tiene que trabajar con
instituciones como el banco mundial como
la vida en el caso de américa latina por
ejemplo como otras como la unesco y la
hoy se ve para que la década que viene
sea una década de inversión nunca vista
en la educación una última pregunta
señor bloqueas cree usted que de alguna
manera el sector educativo va a salir
fortalecido en el largo plazo como
consecuencia de esta crisis
puede ser depende de cada uno de
nosotros debe ser es debe ser un tema de
consenso político que el tema de la
inversión
de la inversión de la educación
listo señor brawn que hay muchísimas
gracias por su presencia aquí en el
france24
muchas gracias a ustedes eran las
reflexiones del ex ministro de educación
nacional juventud y deportes de francia
el señor yo michelle blanqueo sobre la
escuela como un eje central para la
civilización y también como una
herramienta para la construcción de
libertad y democracia siempre y cuando
las mantengamos abiertas siga con más
información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]
y